His translator, CJ Matsumoto, and of course, Kaz.
First, Koji, let me ask you, you said after the ALCS, all the pressure made you wanna throw up,...
...the pressure of the World Series feel?
Last time I almost threw up, this time I almost cried.
Koji, you actually put in your blog after you won the ALCS, "I'm afraid this isn't real."
How real does winning a World Series feel now?
I still feel that I'm in a dream.
All right, Kaz, you were the rock star of the ALCS trophy presentation.
You haven't been to school in quite a while.
You said you were excited for your dad, how proud are you of your dad tonight?
Good.
How hard are you gonna celebrate tonight, Kaz?
Crazy!
Congratulations!
Thank you guys so much.